all right all right all right will they
divide the nation with their reparation
fixation or California subscribe to a
race-based bribe California's
reparations task force has voted yes on
multiple proposals that will now go to
state lawmakers to consider legislation
among other handouts the task force
wants to pay 360 Grand each to
approximately 1.8 million black
Californians who had an ancestor
enslaved in the U.S considering how easy
California was defrauded during covid
I'll be expecting a check
so that alone would cost at least 640
billion it would take the average
Californian six months to shoplift that
much
and it's over twice the state's budget
hell with that kind of money you could
build five new Kardashians
Governor Gaston gaffes gasum that's a
good name gasum Gavin newsom's been
strangely silent on the issue probably
because he knows the moment he signs it
his Ambitions for the White House are As
Dead As a Golden Girls reunion
but why should I mean think about it but
why should California monopolize idiocy
Denver councilwoman candy sitabaka is
proposing an idea to fund reparations
just tax white-owned businesses
disproportionately after all wasn't
capitalism built on Stolen land stolen
labor and stolen resources
capitalism was built on Stolen land
stolen labor and stolen resources and
there are structures that we have that
could be flipped to begin to do that
redis that reparations instead of a bid
collecting extra taxation from the black
and brown businesses that are struggling
you could be collecting those extra
taxes from white-led businesses all over
the city and redistributing them to
black and brown owned businesses oh yeah
that's great
don't we do that already though I'm
pretty sure the millions I pay in taxes
are not going to things that I actually
use like super Yachts gold-plated toilet
seats and of course kidnapping insurance
anyway I feel bad for her she hates
America more than 100 Biden hates bring
your daughter to work day
all right cat
um imagine you're living in California
you had you didn't you didn't have any
slaves your family came from Poland I
think right yes yes both of those are
true
like when you wouldn't it be in your
right to sue the state for taking for
basically theft well yeah this is never
going to actually happen and they know
that which is I mean it would cost like
2.5 times the annual budget is the
estimate and the legality of it is
obviously
probably not going to be allowed so it's
a great way for politicians to say okay
this sounds great it's like when a
friend's like oh I would help you bury a
body it's like okay you know that I'm
never going to ask you to do that but
you will can you pick up my cat from the
vet and then they're like well no I
wouldn't do that
so it's really easy to try to be like
look how much I care that I will offer
this really really awesome intense huge
thing to you but really you're offering
nothing because it is so intense it'll
never actually happen yeah Jay what do
you think of this if you were living in
California in this past would you move I
could not I could not stay there no I'd
open a pizza shop called Black owned
Pizza
you name it whatever you want
this is such a radical idea that I'm
concerned it's like
one racist doing this you ever see the
thing where they tell people they've won
free Yankees tickets and they just get
them all to come to a warehouse yes and
arrest them for like child support
payments or something
just one lunatics trying to get all the
black people to migrate to California
and then something crazy is going to
happen you're right it's a wild thing
come here we'll give you a billion bucks
sorry yes it's a trap I'd go yes I would
too I don't think it's going to happen
what do you think Jamie this is so crazy
I won tickets to the NBA Playoffs I'm
not going to pick them up
at that warehouse
as if it's out of where and whatever you
do when you walk in there don't have
like a uh some like a six-pack of Mike's
Hard Lemonade
[Laughter]
um free game yes I don't know we
actually tried this in Alaska but it
didn't cost that much money because
there's only one black guy
[Laughter]
um
when it comes to numbers like this I
can't even I don't understand like yeah
I also was confused because it's like
whatever the numbers are like they're
gonna pay 200 billion and the budget is
like a hundred billion isn't that not
you don't you don't get what a budget is
yes because you it's twice as much of it
I just can't wrap my hat around billions
and millions of dollars like I try to
figure it out in terms that I would
understand and I was like 200 billion
dollars that would be like if I did I'd
have to do 200 billion gigs
laughs
that's like a load of money yeah that's
sad Jamie yeah you know uh Harold we
talked about this on the five right
remember that good times huh we shared a
lot we have to tell everything yeah but
I did bring up the point that you are
biracial so this is like half of your
body wants the money but the other half
doesn't right it's a psychic there's
like this internal battle I'll convince
I'll convince the other half to keep it
though
this is this is things like this happen
and I give Greg a lot of credit we had a
conversation about this on the show
several weeks back and we talked about
what should be done because we if we
can't agree that there was a wrong that
was done and in fact people back when
the wrong was done agreed and they
proposed to give black people for black
black families 40 acres and a mule they
then reneged on that so there was there
was an admission that there was a wrong
now this answer to your point Point's
been made is absolutely ludicrous I want
in your black owned pizza deal if you
decide to open one up but this is not
going to work this is not going to
happen for the reasons that have been
said and the fact that it's twice the
size of the budget so why why why Bes
Merchant belittle the bigness of the
issue by dumb remedies what we should be
thinking about are ways in which we can
pay this going forward whether it's
seriously thinking about how you educate
kids and holding those schools
accountable in these neighborhoods where
kids are not learning seriously
providing tax incentives for companies
to come in and invest and hire people in
those communities rich kids get tutor
poor kids should get educated and
tutored as well these are the things
including putting making Broadband
accessible in all these communities
where oftentimes you go through some of
these neighborhoods and your phones
don't work they don't work as well as
they do in other neighbors these are the
kinds of my drugs
these are the kinds of things we should
be thinking about as opposed to
nonsensical ideas that won't work I'm
happy to come to Alaska and double that
population if you guys do decide do
decide to do something differently but
it's nonsense to talk about this and
again it it it makes the issue it
distorts the importance of the issue but
okay we got to go but I got to say all
of the things that you mentioned make
sense but they're always they never
happen it's usually the white
Progressive that doesn't like it right
it's like if you want to go into a
community then they call that what do
they call that uh what's the word uh
what are you trying to gentrification
yeah yeah yeah and then if you leave
it's called white flight so you can't
win no matter what and then they call
them food deserts but then when the
places move in and they get they get
shoplifted and they leave then you have
a food desert again it's like it's like
I wish that and we had to do the things
that keep them if it's more police if
it's more teachers you pay teachers more
to look to fund the police well then we
should move them out of the conversation
we have great things going on in this
city a school called Success Academy and
you have a lot of my people in my party
who have to the left of me who don't
like some of the things they're doing
the kid kids are learning at a rate
better and faster than they are in the
best private schools in the city that's
what we ought to be replica I would pay
for that
well I'm saying that figuratively I
still want to go to the left you're not
getting near my money nobody up next RFK
Junior on the CIA plot the day Kennedy
was shot hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else